je pensais pas que le monde allait
ces fonderies de mon vivant mais j'étais
convaincu que ça allait s'effondrer dans
la génération de mes enfants
[Musique]
comment ça va ça va craquer comment ça
va craquer et c'est qui qui va subir les
conséquences
les gens qui vont être capables de
passer au travers l'effondrement sont
pas nécessairement ceux qui vont avoir
le meilleur banker c'est vraiment ce
qu'ils vont être capables de travailler
ensemble
[Musique]
tu est difficile de mettre le doigt sur
qu'est-ce qui va déclencher
merci qu' il ya plusieurs systèmes dans
lesquels ça va être de plus en plus
difficile
tu me demandes si je colle absolue ou
survivalistes ou non les étiquettes là
j'en ai rien à cirer
moi je vis ma vie selon ce que je vois
ce que j'observe ce que je ressens
puis quand je regarde le monde autour de
moi je trouve ça vraiment pas normal
qu'est ce qui se passe autour de moi je
suis aimé vivre de façon humaine
[Musique]
la collection logis c'est une approche
qui vise à étudier les risques
d'effondrement de notre civilisation
les personnes qui s'y intéresse peuvent
rapidement tomber dans un tunnel de 4
d'information qui est assez anxiogène
parce qu elle se renseigne sur toutes
sortes de phénomènes comme les
changements climatiques
l'appauvrissement des sols est les
pénuries en eau le manque de ressources
est facteur qui à eux seuls ou combinés
les uns aux autres peuvent fragiliser ou
même au front certains des systèmes
desquels on dépend mais des fois la peur
et l'anxiété ça peut être des moteurs
puissants pour agir on a voulu
rencontrer des personnes qui sont
tellement convaincus qu'un effondrement
qui s'en vient probablement de leur
vivant qu'ils ont déjà commencé à
changer leur mode de vie a inventé un
nouveau monde un monde qui est basé son
étude communauté l'entr'aide et le
partage
on est à saint valérien c'est un tout
petit village près de rimouski
ici à plusieurs personnes qui se sont
installées pour améliorer leur
résilience individuelles et collectives
comme noémie biyong qu'on s'en va
rencontrer
alors bon après ça va vous en noémie
guillaume partagent leur temps entre une
petite maison qu'ils ont louée
temporairement et un atelier prêté par
un ami qui leur apprend les rudiments de
l'ébénisterie et prépare un beau projet
de construction on est fraîchement
arrivé dans la région y aura donc l'été
passé je travaillais encore comme
physiothérapeute en hôpital à montréal
puis finalement j'ai décidé prendre une
année sabbatique pour réfléchir
changer pour un mode de vie qui
correspond plus à nos valeurs
j'ai quitté mon emploi carrément moi je
voyais pas mon avenir encore en
entreprise même si c'est moi qui font
des mois qu'ils choisissent et mes
horaires etc
je voulais quelque chose qui est à plus
de valeurs humaines que ça aide vraiment
concrètement les gens autour de moi
la réflexion autour de la collecte aux
logiques ce qui m'a amené c'est le
sentiment d'urgence
c'est vraiment le livre de pablo serving
comment tout peut s'effondrer qui m'a
fait le déclic je ne pensais pas que ça
allait affecter autant que ça à moitié
du livre j'ai même comme hésité à
continuer près six mois en fait ça me
fait l'effet de soulagement des eaux les
impressions qu'il ya quelque chose qui
cloche mais de manière
c'était mme x ont fondu j'étais pas tout
seul à passer quelque chose qui avait
vraiment de la science derrière c'était
cette impression de doigts se limite à
tous niveaux à cause de notre mode de
vie où il faudrait aller nous ce serait
justement vers une décroissance produire
moins partagés plus et décider ensemble
comme les vivres marie abraham dans son
livre guérir du mal de l'infini après
une certaine réflexion ça nous a poussés
à déménager à l'extérieur des grandes
villes pour ça qu'on a et dans le
bas-saint-laurent se rapprocher de la
nature
le retour à la terre c'est pas une
nouvelle mode
déjà dans les années 70 d'abord en
californie qu'un peu partout il y avait
des communautés qui tentait de vivre en
harmonie avec la nature notamment en
construisant des maisons autonomes
on a fait un petit saut dans lanaudière
pour rencontrer la première personne qui
a construit une de ces habitations le au
québec on s'en va voir hélène dubé
hélène dubé et vit dans une maison qui
est spécial parce qu'elle le construite
elle même avec son homme y vivent là
depuis 15 ans ils utilisent des panneaux
solaires pour leur électricité ils sont
déconnectés du réseau d'hydro-québec
ils sont sortis du système moi je veux
savoir comment ils vivent comment ils
ont fait c'est quoi une john f
l'astre concept d'abord de maisons
autonomes
on utilise des matériaux à recycler des
déchets on recycle l'eau de la maison la
réutilisent qu'au lieu d'utiliser du
béton pour faire les fondations
lancement on utilise des vieux pneus ont
rempli de terre battue ça fait des
moeurs super solide super résistant
facile à construire puis qui coûte à peu
près on veut vraiment être le plus en
circuit fermé possible mon but il ya
déjà 25 30 ans quand je pensais à ma
maison
c'était de ne pas avoir à dépendre du
système en branchant à hydro je restais
avec un cordon ombilical qui meurent
liesse le système là on surveille
toujours nos niveaux d'électricité ça
peut arriver que dans le temps de noël
si on regarde pas de fin on est trop
limité les jours son cours oui oui puis
sont souvent pas très ensoleillé puis
fait que c'est de la gestion mais c'est
une habitude
ça devient une habitude de vie de vivre
avec le soleil oui je pense pas qu'on
peut sortir complètement du système mais
je pense qu'il ya moyen de s'organiser
pour que si jamais le système est de ne
pas avoir à dépendre du système de quoi
a besoin pour vivre
puis je le pense souvent dans les cours
que je donne tu sais quoi des cours de
besoin pour vivre
pas besoin d'air peut autant possible
qu'ils quittent rendre malade a besoin
d'eau potable
puis tu as besoin une bouffe l'argent ça
se mange pas
pour moi c'est clair depuis longtemps qu
on s'envole vers un mur
est-ce que la race humaine va
disparaître tout poste un peu plus à ma
question qu est ce qu il va y avoir des
catastrophes
il ya toujours une fin du monde pour
quelque chose quelque part sauf qu'en ce
moment il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de fin du monde qui s'accumulent pour
toutes sortes d'espèces vivantes
ça fait juste pas de sens les modes de
vie d'hélène est difficile à envisager
pour la plupart d'entre nous et c'est
encore plus difficile de s'imaginer
qu'elle ciel pourrait nous tomber sur la
tête jean rolland est ce qu'on pourrait
vraiment se retrouver submergé par une
série de catastrophes
cet automne l'uqam à lancer de nouveaux
programmes résilience et gestion de
risque de catastrophe présente les
scénarios catastrophes comme étant il y
aura plus de pétrole par client ne
pullulent pas et puis dos il y en a plus
nulle part dans ce procès c'est que à
certains moments on va en manquer donc
est-ce que ça va nous affecter ici oui
comment on peut naviguer à travers ce
manque là oui on se prépare et on y
étudie parce que ça va arriver c'est
quoi la plus grosse menace le qui nous
pend au bout du nez
je vous dirais que tout ce qu'ils voient
tout ce qui va toucher plusieurs
secteurs de la société et la pandémie en
est un très bel exemple on note chez
autant l'éducation l'économie la santé
publique le monde la culture
le plus grand problème qu'on va avoir à
gérer c'est les réfugiés climatiques
est ce que nous sommes capables demain
matin
faire rentrer un million de personnes
qui n'ont plus d'endroit pour lui parce
que notre mode de vie a fait en sorte
qu'ils se retrouvent dans cette
situation parce que la grèce on va juste
la voir dans le fait que ça soit
inondations à l'essai mais sécheresse
les temps dans le lauragais peu importe
le niveau de la marque monde sort n'aura
pas le choix
ce qu'on peut faire c'est faire en sorte
que collectivement on soit capable
d'accueillir ces gens là au lieu de les
laisser dans des lits que la seule règle
souvent et évoque une perte de leur mode
de vie est ce que c'est une vision
cauchemardesque
est-ce que c'est des alarmistes est-ce
qu'il ya quelque chose de productif dans
ce discours moi je pense que quelque
chose de productif
à se préparer à une transformation de
notre système que les gens qui se
rassemblent en fait il se prépare à un
manque de ressources si on pense la
décroissance qui est de consommer moins
c'est consommer ce qu'on a besoin quand
il va avoir une diminution des
ressources disponibles
c'est vers ce qu'il va falloir aller les
gens qu'on a rencontrés c'est pas des
survivalistes des gens qui au lieu de
s'enfermer dans un bunker et c'est de
créer des titres communauté d'écrivains
jardins de s'intéresser à la
permaculture
est ce que ça vous semble viable comme
solution faire face à certaines crises
ce genre de communauté l'eau me fascine
parce que c'est des gens qui réussissent
ensemble a justement centre et des
ischios nice souvenir la première des
choses qu'on a à faire c'est développer
ce qu'on appelle réseau social le
capital social si on veut prendre les
termes scientifiques donc c'est de
s'assurer que la personne qui est seule
nos gens vulnérables on les connaît on
sait sont rouen n'est qu'à de leur venir
en aide
on l'a vu pendant la pandémie il ya
beaucoup de gens que ce sont eux qui ont
commencé à s'intéresser à leurs voisins
c'est ce qu'il faut faire
donc le réseau social c'est
indissociable de la résilience hélène
dubé et le 6eme confié d'ailleurs qu'il
sentait pas tout à fait prête à faire
face à un effondrement
selon elle ça lui prendrait environ 150
à 200 personnes autour de sa maison des
gens sur qui elle pourrait compter et
vice versa mais enseigner la
permaculture
c'est un moyen qu'il a trouvé pour
partager ses connaissances et créer du
lien
des armes se palpent il parle aux
champignons aps les champignons fonds
l'interconnexion entre les armes puis
c'est tout
c'est tout les résoudre c'est pas parce
que nous on ne sait pas qui on le
comprend pas que ça existe pas la
permaculture s'est basé sur une éthique
qui fondamentale qui est trop trois
choses prendre soin de la terre prendre
soin des gens puis redistribué
équitablement les surplus enseigner la
permaculture j'aime beaucoup c'est
motivant c'est une partie de la solution
je pense
[Musique]
moi je vraiment accros de tribus c'est
mon truc
certains d'entre eux dans ce moment
elles sont trop éparpillé on est encore
obligé de se déplacer en voiture
il faut qu'ils soient capables d'avoir
tout ce dont on a besoin à l'intérieur
d'un périmètre que tu peux marcher au
cas où il n'y a plus d'essence par
exemple donc juste pour qui ça avait du
sens on peut finalement bien vivre ou
répondre à ses besoins primaires si on
est seul ça prend une tribu c'est un peu
solides et sont très rares les humains
qui sont capables de vivre dernier
thouet sont très rares les humains qui
vivent pas en ermite quand ils sont dans
une ville d'un million d'habitants
[Musique]
on
noémie idiome se sont installés à saint
valérien parce qu'ils y ont trouvé une
vie communautaire et des initiatives qui
correspondent à la valeur comme des
projets intergénérationnels et des plans
de résilience alimentaire
ils se sont aussi liés d'amitié avec
guylaine vézina une conseillère
municipale qui s'intéresse elle aussi
elle a collectionné
vue directe sur le fleuve et sur le
coucher de soleil quant à beat si tu dis
pourquoi j'ai d'ailleurs on essaie
vraiment le paradis si mylène est
impliqué dans toutes sortes de projets
au village quand on l'a rencontré un
groupe de bénévoles assembler des
paniers de denrées alimentaires dans une
église qui a trouvé une nouvelle
vocation
déjà le fait qu'on ait transformer
l'église dans ce sens communautaire
ça fait un lieu justement attirant dans
les citoyens ont pris en charge cette
bâtisse là je soude et la communauté
ensemble pour moi on va dire ça passe ou
ça casse c'est sûr qu'il ya toute la
résilience alimentaire c'est sûr que si
on mange pour on va pas aller loin on
est d'accord mais à partir du moment où
les besoins de base sont sont assurés ça
te connais quelque chose à manger puis
on a un toit sur notre tête la pierre
angulaire d'une résilience une
communauté c'est est ce qu'on est
capable de vivre ensemble sens tactique
on est une espèce on a survécu trois
cent mille ans pas parce qu'on avait un
gros serveur mais parce qu'on avait une
intelligence collective parce que on est
complètement démunis comme comme comme
animal sérieusement a lâché tout nu dans
en forêt là un ours fengyang avec nous
autres mais si on est plusieurs
le ça change
vivre à plusieurs pour mylène d une
heure c'est tout sur un projet qu'elle
veut lancer avec d'autres familles le
projet d'éco hameau
ils veulent construire un bâtiment
écologique multi logements adjacents un
bâtiment comme aujourd'hui ils
construisent un fort attrait ennemis
leur donne un coup de main parce qu'on
est très très riche on peut se permettre
des choses que personne au puisse
permettre avant nous comme être humain
on n'a plus besoin de développer nos
compétences relationnelles pour vivre
ensemble le fait d'habiter chacun dans
nos maisons que les enfants aient chacun
leur chambre d'avoir deux trois voitures
par ménage de pouvoir manger des tout ce
qu'on veut n'importe quand dans l'année
de ne pas avoir de restriction sur à peu
près sur l'eau sur le chauffage sur
l'énergie qu'on utilise ça s'est jamais
vu encore dans l'histoire de l'humanité
quand tu casses cette manière de vivre
très individuelle dans chaque petit
appartement de ce travail dans ta
voiture des objets etc et que tu vas en
collectivité tout est mélangé tout est
partagé d'antan les gens
ronfler et c'est pas ça implique à
discuter avec les gens à confronter les
idées et et on n'a pas été habitué et
peut-être qu'il y a pas fonctionné pour
les lipides pour la période de 70 c'est
ce côté là qu il croyait que c'est juste
en se rassemblant salle et ça les a
arrangés la différence maintenant c'est
encore une fois l'urgence
d'urgence fait qu'à un moment donné si
on allait des ressources très limitées
ben il est avec nous noémie guillaume
ont décidé de se construire une mini
maisons mobiles qu'ils pourront
éventuellement déposées au sein d'une
communauté comme celle de mylène a lot
of là la base mobile qui étonnerait
marco qu'on ne fait pas son maître donc
elle fait 25 pieds sur huit et la
hauteur de la bâtisse va être à peu près
à 13 pieds car on veut essayer de
trouver des solutions pour économiser le
plus d'eau possible donc on veut capter
l'eau par dans le toit et faire une
réserve en dessous de la maison ce n'est
pas être dans ta mine mais ancré dans
son coin
dans notre manière à nous d'abord notre
espace personnel n'est des trois
participantes qui collective quand même
on va voir ça bouge parce qu'on est
habitués comme ça donc on veut avoir un
petit repli non à minima
[Musique]
mais si jamais ça arrive pas disons le
conte à boulder club
est ce que ça changerait votre mode de
vie non il faut vraiment que ce soit par
par conviction par choix par plaisir par
plaisir aussi parce que tu retrouves
beaucoup tant de qualité de vie vraiment
à faire ces choses certaines choses toi
même
moi je trouve ça beaucoup plus
intéressant d'apprendre toujours de
nouvelles choses que d'ajouter des
cordes à mon arc que d'être assis
pendant 50 ans derrière un bureau à
faire toujours la même chose si c'est
juste d'être plus débrouillards tourisme
importe le scénario qui voyage
on peut vraiment transformer la société
radicalement ensemble
pour le bien commun pour le bien de
l'environnement et c'est vraiment
satisfaisant ainsi ça amène peut-être
quelque chose de nouveau et plus
équitable pour tout le monde
si aucun effondrement tant mieux et en
plus on va participer à un mode de vie
qui a du sens avec nos valeurs puis on
va avoir participé quelque chose qui est
positif
globalement pour nous mais aussi
collectivement donc tant mieux si c'est
pas quartier
la fin d'un monde le début d'un nouveau
ça évoque quoi en vous on veut le savoir
écrivez nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]